philippe allard délégué syndical cgt
carrefour bonsoir philippe allard merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france
l'entreprise carrefour n'aurait pas pris
en tout cas toutes les mesures
nécessaires à la protection des
questionnaires notamment est ce le cas
oui on à la cgt groupe carrefour
on est très en colère contre la
direction parce que dès le début de la
bd de l'épidémie on avait sollicité la
direction pour que justement il ya il ya
une régulation des flux clients c'est à
dire que c'est la première c'est la
première comment dire nous nous
demandons clairement que la direction
réguler le flux clients qui empêche les
salariés les clients de rentrer
massivement dans les magasins c'est la
première des choses pour permettre à ces
aux salariés d'avoir un périmètre de
sécurité
la deuxième chose que l'on réclame
depuis le depuis le départ c'est d'avoir
des gants tout simplement d'avoir du gel
hydro alcoolique et il est en train
d'arriver les masques alexandre bompard
à l'annoncé 10 millions de masques en
france ils sont en cours de livraison
là par exemple dans un entrepôt il ya
deux matches qui sont arrivés pour pour
la logistique et la direction refuse de
les doter les salariés de de ces masques
parce qu'ils estiment que cana pas assez
pour tout le confinement c'est un
véritable scandale ce qui se passe à
carrefour c'est à dire que non seulement
il ya d'autres très peu les salariés de
gants et de gênes et 3 alcoolique mais
en plus il ne souhaite pas donner les
masques actuellement aux salariés est-ce
que c'est limité à carrefour saint denis
où est ce que vous le constatez dans les
carrefours de france on a vu beaucoup de
supermarchés effectivement garder c'est
ce mètres de distance
faire entrer les
les consommateurs au compte-gouttes
justement c'est pas le cas du tout dans
les grandes surfaces carrefour
non non c'est pas du tout le cas le cas
c'est en fonction justement du rapport
de force qui a dans les magasins nous ce
qu'on dénonce et ça c'est qu'à chaque
fois il faut instaurer le rapport de
force dans les magasins pour que le flux
clients soient respectés et du coup la
distance de sécurité pour l'épauler
salariés respectés c'est un véritable
scandale
c'est une la course aux profits
bourbourg carrefour carrefour profite
clairement du conte du confinement pour
faire du profit au détriment de la
sécurité et la santé des salariés ce cru
ce que nous ayons des danses encore une
fois est-ce que vous notez une influence
identiques en tous cas c'est l'habituel
j'imagine que les gens font toujours
leurs courses et c'est vrai que deux
îles des supermarchés ont vu leurs
ventes considérablement augmentée c'est
le cas pour carrefour
pour carrefour et pour la grande
distribution de façon générale c'est
tous les jours noël tous les jours noël
pour carrefour
mais malheureusement pas pour les
salariés par exemple là les salariés qui
se sentent en danger exercent leur droit
de retrait légitime pour se retirer du
danger la direction carrefour on voit
des courriers aux salariés concernés je
vais vous lire quand même la phrase qui
est effarante
c'est en cas de refus de votre part que
nous serons contraints d'effectuer une
retenue sur votre salaire et en plus
éventuellement d'engager une procédure
disciplinaire pouvant entraîner une
sanction non seulement ses salariés la
kiss qui souhaite ne pas être mis en
danger au mans qui travaillent la
direction carrefour les menacent
clairement de licenciement c'est un
véritable scandale ce qui se passe et ce
que j'imagine que les employés carrefour
vont travailler sauf conditions
particulières de garde d'enfant c'est la
seule condition qui permettent à des
employés de carrefour de ne pas venir
effectivement il ya la carte d'enfants
de deux des enfants de moins de 16 ans
mais il ya aussi malheureusement des
salariés qui ont été touchés par le
conte à virus
il n'y a à peu près une centaine dans le
groupe carrefour et nous demandons nous
il ya des suspection suspection aussi de
deux salariés touchés par le grand
chrono virus nous demandent clairement
que tous les salariés qui ont été en
contact avec les salariés qui ont été
touchés par le cornard virus soit mis en
14 n ce qui refusait totalement par par
carrefour qui refusent de d'accepter que
le salarié restent chez eux quand il ya
suspicion de grands navires us dans un
magasin qu'en est il de la personne
décédée cette caissière de 52 ans qui
est décédé
on a vu sa photo évidemment mon a montré
hier également sur notre antenne qui
était cet cette dame et elle a continué
à travailler j'imagine pendant le début
de cette crise c'est tout à fait ça
c'est aïcha c'est qu'en deux ans délégué
syndical cgt à l'été avec les collègues
de travail jusqu'au 16 mars
et malheureusement elle est tombée
malade le 17 mars il y avait décidé hier
c'est dans l'exercice nous sommes
vraiment de cette sanction qu'elle a été
touchée par le courant d'un virus vous
l'aviez vu à ce moment-là vous la
connaissiez je ne la connaissais pas
personnellement mais je l'avais oui
effectivement vu à plusieurs reprises en
réunion à paris qu'en est-il des
consommateurs est ce que eux respectent
au moins selon vous de ce que vous
pouvez observer en tout cas les les
mesures de sécurité mais nous on n'en
veut pas aux consommateurs
il faut savoir que la france est bloquée
et que la seule activité pour les
usagers il est client en france et
d'aller dans les magasins
donc nous on demande vraiment un
carrefour de prendre disposition
d'embaucher des agents de sécurité de
pour réguler le flux l'usagé il n'a pas
le choix il faut qu'il faut bien qu'ils
fassent quelque chose il va dans ses
magasins et nous on reproche vraiment un
carrefour de parcours des dispositions
pour protéger les clients et les
salariés des magasins
merci beaucoup philippe allard d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france
merci